Rafi wrote in saying what happened to
people you guys went to high school with
that the class clowns end up successful
what happened to the bullies any
interesting stories yeah I there's a lot
of interesting ones I mean but yeah big
if I had the big picture it the kids who
were quote popular in high school I
didn't go to a prime into a public
school which maybe had a broader
cross-section of students right I know
people who went to private schools where
everybody's just doing well the people
who were quote popular in high school
are by and large not necessarily doing
as well as you would expect and many of
the people who were doing best are
individuals who were not outcasts but
certainly maybe had smaller groups of
friends fewer friends were less popular
seemed more academically oriented etc my
sense Lewis is that that's the big
picture for our high school graduating
class yes it was about 205 students yeah
I agree that's pretty much what happened
there are some exceptions yeah
but generally it was kind of a a
reversal it's hard in high school people
always come in Rachel and they say you
know the stuff that you think matters
right now it's not going to matter not
only won't it matter later in life it
won't even matter next year when you're
in college and it's hard to believe that
when you're in high school many times
but in a lot of ways it really does end
up being true whatever sort of
establishes these hierarchies in high
school often times is of no relevance or
or indicator I mean the class well yeah
you know what actually I'm now realizing
I'm identifying specific people I don't
want to say anything specific but there
are just a lot of these surprises ten
years at five ten years later when you
look back aren't there yeah and I would
say the theme that you mentioned
definitely held true in my high school
as well it was a little bit different
for me because I was in this kind of
small democratic learning institution
which was definitely more focused on
academics and less kind of on social
hierarchy and things of that nature so
for me personally it wasn't as big of an
issue but I've definitely noticed that
trend hold true for what I've seen I've
talked to some people Louis who went to
private schools and they say this whole
thing of like the popular kids and the
unpopular kids it didn't exist in my
school because the administration was
just so involved in making sure there
were
outcasts and the bullied etc that the
entire concept of that I've only heard
about it from people who went to public
school which I can't imagine every we
know that there are private high schools
where there is significant bullying
hazing and clique eNOS no doubt it could
have just been that the people you speak
to were oblivious to it that could be as
as people who to many people who tend to
go to private schools can be oblivious
about a great many things Wow well so
Lewis's critique there how does that
ring yeah I mean I don't really think
that tactic by administration in private
schools is really that beneficial who is
that going to benefit in the long run
because I feel like when you're in high
school you've learned how to deal with
all different types of people yeah later
on when you're in college when you're in
a working environment when you're
working on some sort of group project so
I don't really know if that's the best
kind of way to go I tend to agree it's
the same idea of the college safe space
protecting students from anything that
might be upsetting in what way does that
better prepare you for the real world
that being said a high school freshman
is very different than a high school
senior and a high school senior is very
different than a college senior so I
think it's important to sort of bear in
mind the age of the kids that we're
talking about but big picture Louis I
agree
protecting all children from everything
in the real world long term is not a
benefit no a detriment actually very
harmful